such a uh interesting
interesting week in the news a big
mystery was solved this week you know
some and a couple of months ago was that
leaking National very sensitive National
Security information on the internet
well this week ladies and gentlemen we
got him the FBI arrested a 21 year old
uh Air National Guardsmen in
Massachusetts who was doing this and I
had so many questions I want to know why
a 21 year old had access to her most
secret national security stuff when
when most of them need to Google how to
write a check I
and wait
it gets more gen Z than this he
he was living with his mom
and where did he post this sensitive
stuff in an online chat room for video
gamers
so we know one thing about the
motivation it wasn't to impress girls
but really
show the picture of this kid this is who
did look at this
and my generation is the problem
that's him the Intel in cell
Jason born yesterday what the
looks like someone used the de-aging
filter on mayor p
the Dalai Lama sucks tongues that are
older than this
this kid got carted at the Super Mario
Brothers movie
when they asked him for a police said
Not Guilty by reason of anxiety I I'm
telling you these kids today
and here's I love this part of this
story the person who identified this
leaker this 21 year old liquor was it
younger a teenage boy which makes sense
because all the people in the chat room
were teenage boys the 21 year old was
known as the OG I'm not kidding
he was trying to impress them you know
what he named the group they were in
this little clubhouse the thug Shaker
Central Thug Shaker Central
also will be the name of his ass when he
goes to prison
I love this Wrinkle in the story
Marjorie teller green is siding with the
leaker
with the kid she said he said he's white
male and Christian
yeah
so he can't do anything bad she said ask
yourself who's the real enemy you
Marjorie you
you are the Real Enemy
I mean in this
it's so hard to wrap your head about
what goes on in the minds of these
self-style Patriots
they love America so much they
absolutely hate it
Marjorie is going to open a new chain of
grocery stores called Trader hoes
I mean it's all funny haha but the stuff
that was revealed with this leak is
super serious we find out that this
looks bad that America has been spying
on our own allies which might be good
because one of our allies Egypt sort of
uh their President we found out from
this is wants to send artillery to
Russia probably artillery we paid for
we found out there's an Informer that we
have at the highest level in the Russian
military so expect a bunch of people to
be falling out of Windows in Moscow next
week oh and I love this we found out
that Iran Iran wants to start a space
mission
wow they want to land on the moon gather
some moon rocks bring them back and
throw them at Israel
and
again this is super serious we this
thing revealed that Ukraine that war is
not going as they told us all that well
they said Ukraine very low on ammunition
and we were going to send them more but
uh Kid Rock used it all to shoot at Bud
Light
foreign